is it worth it to be tracked by all of
them you know they're all sitting around
watching on a screen eating popcorn
whenever you do anything and uh just so
that you can send out this message so
you never get lost in the woods you guys
want to hear something really really
crazy
so Dennis is uh one of our filmers and
uh he was hanging out downstairs in the
Green Room when Ali got here and all of
a sudden he goes what the and then he
shows me his Instagram had one of
Ollie's videos and he was like I've
never heard of this guy before like why
is his video appearing oh you were
coming that happened to me earlier I was
I'm filming this morning and um with
turning points and we were talking about
a specific subjects about the uganda's
laws with the LGBT and it came up on his
phone and he never searches for that
kind of content then something else we
were talking about came up so it's
definitely weird so there's good and bad
things about technology like with the
cases Maori that's obviously saved a
family's life you now have on Apple with
car crashes um it actually alerts
emergency services to come so there's
benefits but it's very scary when they
can actually listen to us